processing loss is something that
shaquille o'neal has had to do a lot he
recently lost his sister and of course
his good friend kobe bryant yesterday
marked the one-year anniversary of
kobe's death
and in this exclusive interview shaq
told me his first thought
was for kobe's family
i was more worried about his mom because
you know i'm a mama's boy so i just
like that's the uh first thing i did
when i woke up and just called miss
brown and i just let her know that
i love her because look it was a tough
day but
you know for vanessa and the kids and
for his parents it was a tougher day so
i just wanted to make sure that they
were okay
and how was she was she was she doing
okay she
she was doing okay under the uh
unfortunate circumstances
after kobe's death last year shaq
donated proceeds from his annual super
bowl party to the crash victims families
this year he's also helping others
you're auctioning off your shoes
well i'm auctioning off my shoes with
boys and girls well i think it's part of
my responsibility to you know help take
care of children so
are you going to try to go to the game
or are you contributing
i'm going to be at the super bowl lady
you're going to be at the game
of course are you excited for the
weekend
oh listen the weekend is elections gonna
do something big
next sunday's shack bowl is big two
welcome to shaq's fun house
streaming on 20 different platforms with
a star squad
okay so team kansas city is going to be
diplo ezekiel elliott
olivia corpo huevo stevo and the miz and
team tampa bay is going to be anthony
anderson
drew mcintyre nelly offset tim tebow and
winnie
and it's clear he's not rooting for my
kansas city chiefs
i think there needs to be a wager on
this game okay so
if if the chiefs win then you'll go
tandem skydiving
wait that's a win for you that's not a
[Music]
win
you